Ça n'est pas par hasard si nous
démarrons par celle-là.
Vous savez Aurélien le disait à l'instant dans le petit film de présentation
c'est un Français sur trois qui est
concerné, c'est 11 millions d'aidants.
Qu'on ne se préoccupe pas de ce sujet et
qu'on ne le porte pas!
Quelle doit être la place que nous réservons aux personnes porteuses d'un handicap?
Comment nous favorisons l'insertion dans le milieu ordinaire?
Comment effectivement nous allons
améliorer la situation de façon à ce que
chacun d'entre nous puisse se
révéler au sein de notre République?
C'est ça l'ADN de la Droite républicaine ;
valeurs de solidarité.
Les Républicains depuis plusieurs mois, cherchent à se mettre à la hauteur des Français.
A ne pas être au-dessus des Français.
22 millions de nos concitoyens sont de près concernés par le handicap.
Cette vision là, que nous allons développer ce soir, au travers d'une série de témoignages,
une série de discussions, d'échanges et de propositions.
C'est une vision de la politique et de la République.
Nous sommes très fiers aussi au sein du groupe LR au Sénat
d'être à l'origine du groupe handicap qui a été créé il y a cinq ans
et pouvoir vous dire également que notre mouvement politique est également présent au sein du CNCPH,
Conseil national consultatif des personnes handicapées.
Donc nous portons également notre voix et nos convictions au sein de cette instance importante.
Il est donc véritablement urgent que l'Etat montre l'exemple.
L'éducation nationale devra recruter comme je disais à l'instant trente mille personnes en situation de handicap
et donc remplacer un départ à la retraite sur six par une personne en situation de handicap.
Pour le statut de ces aidants il faut absolument le reconnaître
et aussi dénoncer qu'il ya un manque d'ambition de la part du Gouvernement sur ce sujet.
Nous maintiendrons aussi et ça c'est important parce qu'en ce moment on est un peu dans le flou avec le texte sur les retraites.
C'est les huit trimestres réputés cotisés pour les parents d'enfants en situation de handicap.
Et puis, nous assurons aussi le droit à des formations pour les parents qui le demandent dont les enfants sont en situation de handicap.
J'ai eu la chance de travailler avec
Aurélien durant plusieurs mois
pour préparer cette convention et je vois que c'est l'aboutissement avec dix mesures très très fortes
qui vont redonner encore plus de sens à l'handicap mais sont aussi de l'aide
et essayer de changer le
regard.
C'est vraiment ce qu'on doit faire.
Changer le regard sur le handicap.
La convention était passionnante et intéressante.
Elle correspondait complètement aux enjeux de terrain.
Effectivement dans les dix propositions on peut retenir le statut des aidants
la question de l’AAH qui est remontée quotidiennement par les associations.
Et ce que je retiens c'est : un pragmatisme,
une écoute du terrain avec des témoignages qui correspondaient complètement aussi aux réalités.
Et vraiment on voit que les Républicains sur ce sujet qui est majeur sont en pointe
et continuent dans la tradition de la Droite Républicaine à porter le sujet du handicap.
Ce qui m'a beaucoup intéressée dans cette convention c'est qu'on a abordé la question du handicap psychique
qui est trop souvent oubliée et peu mis en avant et là on a eu un témoignage de l'UNAFAM
et des propositions concrètes pour un sujet qui est trop souvent oublié et qui est fondamental.
Excellente convention sur un thème en ce qui me concerne moi,
qui m'est particulièrement cher, c'est tout ce qui tourne autour de l'autisme
et de la détection de l'autisme chez les plus jeunes.
Pratiquement dans les premiers mois après la naissance
et surtout, le traitement des jeunes adultes
après qu'ils aient été traités alors qu'ils étaient encore mineurs
et qui deviennent une charge très lourde pour leurs parents.
là, y a vraiment un travail à faire
de même qu'il faudra bien évidemment se préoccuper de la formation des aidants.
Sur cette question d'autisme parce qu'il y a beaucoup à faire à ce niveau là.
Je suis venue en tant que médecin
parce que toute ma vie j'ai été confrontée au handicap
et particulièrement à l'handicap psychiatrique.
Nous avons très peu de moyens pour permettre aux malades de se réinsérer dans la vie active
et automatiquement ça entraîne des rechutes fréquentes.
Si, il y avait des moyens de pouvoir les remettre au travail,
de pouvoir avoir une ergothérapie plus active,
qui les parachuteraient dans une vie active,
je suis sûre qu'on pourrait gagner 30 à 40% d'améliorations.
Écoutez, je suis vraiment très heureux
de voir que les Républicains reprennent une thématique qui nous concerne tous au quotidien.
De voir que c'est enfin un sujet d'intérêt général qui est repris par les Républicains.
On sent aujourd'hui, que c'est un sujet qui n'intéresse pas beaucoup les politiques
malgré toutes les difficultés que peuvent rencontrer à la fois les familles
et à la fois les personnes handicapées
et de pouvoir travailler sur un grand nombre de propositions.
Dix propositions étaient données ce soir, pour aider les personnes handicapées,
aider les aidants et puis retrouver le courage aussi de réaffirmer des
propositions politiques dans notre
société me paraît aussi primordial.
Élu départemental avec aussi une MDPH et nous avons besoin aussi
nous les départements de nous améliorer dans les réponses faites aux personnes handicapées.
Aujourd'hui, on a besoin de mieux évaluer leur situation, on a besoin de mieux les accompagner
et je pense que c'est un travail qu'on peut faire aussi sur le plan national.
Donc, bravo aux Républicains et bravo à tous ceux qui ont travaillé sur cette convention pour améliorer
les conditions des personnes handicapées en France.